on screen is the open world map that we
have access to in eldon ring's network
test it contains 10 bosses
15 points of interest seven dungeons
eight npcs and a really impressive
amount of materials items spells and
weapon skills
you have all of this to explore in
preparation for eldon ring's first
legacy dungeon located here called
stormville castle its first boss
margaret the fell is a choke point for
any further progression
put these foolish ambitions to rest
but the network test walls off a section
of this starting open world with walls
of light which prevent you from
exploring more of this starting zone but
if we look at the bigger map that they
revealed in a video recently
you realize that god damn the content we
have access to in the network test seems
like less than half of the starting open
world there's still an island to the
south and there's a ton of landmass to
the east
and this is just the starting open world
before stormville castle who knows
really how much open world they've
designed up there to the north west
having a big map in an open world game
is one thing but being able to pack it
densely with intriguing events and
encounters that's what makes the game
truly feel huge
so you know if they need to recycle this
man opens door animation one more time
in order for the relatively few
employees of from software to make the
scope of this game achievable then i say
all power to them
so the first thing you're probably going
to do when you leave the tutorial
dungeon is
die
okay that's not true you might kill a
few goats first
but the tree sentinel the wandering
horseman is really difficult without you
having your own mouth and while you can
cheese him in some locations of the open
world i would never do such a thing
instead let's come back later when we
have a horse as well but first follow
the light from every grace until you get
to the gateside ruins this means you'll
sneak in from the south and you'll be in
a really good position to loot the
crimson crystal tear on the right we'll
be able to mix potions with it later
sounds pretty cool right
sneak through to the middle of the camp
and then you can pick up the map
fragment for this area these are really
important items marked by this glowing
rune inscribed tower
it looks like every section of the open
world will have one of these and they're
probably marked by these same towers so
keep an eye out they reveal tons of
details on the map
once you clear the camp or flee from it
take the eastern exit and sit at this
grace here you'll unlock the ability to
level up and receive your mount before
you leave the last really good thing is
a cookbook within a caravan located on
the north side of the camp it teaches
you to craft a bunch of fire related
items and my favorite was fire grease
which is a weapon buff it's the sort of
weapon buff that always suits you well
at the start of these games to access
these recipes and craft items from their
materials you'll have to go back to
kalei at the church of ella and buy a
crafting kit now that you've spent a
little bit of time exploring the world
and killing those sheep you should be
able to craft a few things and you
should have enough runes for a lot of
the stuff that kalei sells the wolf
spirit in particular is one of the
strongest spirits i found despite it
being quite cheap so like a lot of
summons they can die pretty quickly but
the wolves move around a lot which means
they often do a good job of dodging and
staying alive and just distracting
enemies i'm sure some other summons are
dps based but from what i can tell
having them as a distraction while you
do the damage is always going to be a
good strategy carla also sells a torch
which will serve you really well in dark
places obviously most caves have a bit
of light in them you know they've got
campfires or glowstone but even those
caves have dark corners within them that
you'll want to torch for and some caves
are just pitch black so buy this finally
kalei also sells some basic weapons make
sure you pick up the bow that's always
good but another great one to pick up is
the lance because you do a lot of
horseback combat in this game and you
know surprise surprise the lance is
really useful on horseback it lives up
to its true purpose finally and lets you
joust with your enemies now that you
have a horse and a weapon you like
hopefully you can go and get revenge on
the tree sentinel more than the loot it
drops it's just an excellent opportunity
to practice horseback combat with a
grace nearby
like most holy sort of cleric characters
in the game this guy is very anti-magic
literally
he drops the holy ground ash of war a
skill for your shield that consecrates
the ground beneath you healing and
granting defense to any allies that
stand within it between the church of
ella and the gateside ruins is small
forest filled with wandering soldiers
tucked away against the northwestern
cliff here is groveside cave it's one of
the best early dungeons to try and clear
i think first you'll find the twin blade
it's weapon art spinning slash does
great damage and effectively stun locks
the boss of this dungeon showing you
immediately why it's good but what you
really want is this the flask of
wondrous physic that is in a chest
behind the boss it's basically a custom
healing flask that you can fill with
combinations of tear items that you find
in the world
go to a grace to replenish this flask
and customize it with different things
the two tiers it comes with make it
restore stamina and make you explode but
if you like staying alive then you can
replace the explosion part with the
crimson tier that we found earlier at
the gateside ruins and then it restores
your hp instead of getting rid of it the
boss also dropped an amber medallion
which increases your maximum stamina you
have two spots in your equipment screen
for such medallions they seem to
function as rings did in dark souls so
don't forget to equip them and let's go
find a second one at the dragon burnt
ruins at the southern side of agile lake
there are two cellars one contains a
crimson dagger but the other one
contains the crimson medallion which
increases your maximum hp go east from
here and on the edge of the lake you'll
find a couple of crabs
did i say a couple of crabs i meant a
fuckton there's a [ __ ] ton of crabs this
is a great place to carefully farm runes
as kiting the crabs leads them to kill
each other you'll also get glintstone
arc an excellent cleave sorcery here and
i used it to cleave all of the enemies
that are guarding the wandering caravan
which spawns nearby alternatively you
can just hit the giants to stop the
caravan and try to quickly loot your
prize instead this caravan has the
crucible set and weapon a great set to
use if you're planning on doing a
strength build since now strength
increases your equipment load as well so
you can actually you know use the heavy
gear that is associated with a strength
build that's clever the weapon art on
this is cool as hell and it can do a ton
of damage if you're able to fully charge
it
basically everything that you can charge
does a lot of damage so when you do play
remember that you can charge pretty much
everything now you should definitely
hold your bumper buttons and test that
out remember unique weapons like this
have their skills bound to them and you
can't change their skills with ashes of
war like you can for basic weapons like
the lance or battle axe
the post-town remains up ahead on the
east side of the map hide four smithing
shards for your weapon there's also a
secret cellar located in this area you
find it by climbing the ruin above and
then looking down or you can just jump
over its walls with torrent fight the
pumpkin head and then become pumpkin
head and then take pumpkin head off
because it's really heavy sorceress
celine sells sorceries glintstone stars
is a great basic sorcery
meteor is also a fun one for groups of
enemies and bubbles is weak but design
wise i love it i love seeing sorceries
that function as a sort of trap for
enemies i just hope they buff it one of
my favorite things to do in these games
is to run ahead and get a powerful
weapon first and then double back and
clear all of the previous content with
it so you might enjoy doing this next
cave early it gives you the dragon scale
blade one of the best early game weapons
it's quite well hidden in the agile
tunnels
at the north side of the lake as you
explore these tunnels make sure that you
leap off the elevators every time that
you take one there are hidden pathways
here and one of them leads to the stone
digger troll pretty tough boss that
requires very careful spacing so you
should have about five shards by now but
you need one more to get your weapon to
plus two so from the church of ella
let's head to the beach to the south
west and find one more shard here you'll
find the nomadic merchant he sells
crafting materials armor and incantation
but perhaps most importantly he sells
sleep arrows these are very useful in a
variety of situations
on your way here you might have noticed
there was a lone wandering giant coming
up from the beach these guys always drop
a smithing shard so let's get our sixth
one from him
it is nighttime so put him to sleep
permanently
every sleep arrow is a free critical
strike on these guys and there are a ton
of these giants up on storm hill past
the storm gate it's the best place to
farm shards but not just because of the
giants there's also a statue here that
can break giving you a staggering six
shards enough to bring your weapon from
plus two to plus three it's the maximum
you can get it to without a blacksmith
and if you need even more shards you can
explore the other side of storm hill
this smoldering giant is fairly easy to
defeat and he gives you three shards
northeast from here surrounded by
purple-eyed snake creatures is an ever
jail
defeat the bloodhound night inside and
you'll get the barricade ash of war
which is really overpowered it
strengthens your shield while you're
still blocking and it lasts for a while
afterwards making you basically
unkillable as long as your shield has
the right resistances and as long as the
boss isn't applying a bleed effect one
of the last things you'll want to do is
attempt to kill agil the flying dragon
so head down to the lake once more the
best way i found to defeat him was with
a lightning weapon art since dragons are
typically weak to lightning i don't know
if this one is but he is standing in
water which increases its area of effect
the first kill i had on him though was
on horseback you just chip away at him
and that is an option as well if you do
this i'd highly recommend crafting some
horse feed to keep your mouth healthy as
you fight him because it's going to be a
long fight and if you do lose torrent
then you'll have to use a healing flask
to revive him so feed torrent instead
you get uggheel's heart from defeating
him which can be taken to the
southwestern island for dragon communion
to get there just swim across
once you're here there's one small
statue in particular that takes the
heart and gives you grails raw an
incredibly powerful incantation that
deals enormous aoe damage and reduces
enemy attack damage as well for a
limited time behind the dragon church is
feast upon flame it's a chargeable
fireball incantation and a top and
nearby ruin is dragonfire a channeled
flamethrower incantation
speaking of dragonfire go and check out
the guardian the moonlight disc plates
it's something i designed with justin
garad over the last few months and i'm
really proud of this one before i go
though i want to leave you on a quest a
bit of an unsolved mystery at least in
this network test
it has to do with bach a demi-human
hidden in a grove of trees near the
bird's eye telescope oi
you you there
could you help us out cully
oh yes
i remember
some clod turned me into a tree
you were just breaking the spell weren't
you
thank you
the name's bach
i was pushed out of the cave
told not to come back
not ever
then i ended up as a tree
lucky you came along really
or
well if you can afford to wait for a
while
i could sneak back into the cave and
bring back something of actual value
then i'd be of some real use to you i
reckon
right
but i'll need a moment
i'm i'm frightened of them
so i have to gather myself
my knees start knocking just thinking
about that god-awful cave on the shore
the first beach i thought he actually
might be at is by the seaside which
requires some clever platforming to get
down to
this was actually super fun to try and
figure out and i hope from software
doesn't miss the opportunity to put a
lot of tricky platforming in their game
but he's not here instead his map icon
actually shows him at the dissenters
cave to the west
based on his dialogue i assume he is the
dissenter and this cave also contains
other demi humans like him
so why then no matter what we do does he
not show up here we've hit every bush
every wall at every time of day on
multiple characters nothing hopefully
you guys figure it out in the network
test or maybe we can do some more
testing when i stream it but until then
thank you for watching and i'll see you
next time